[Music]
a festive moment in Albania's capital
Tirana for the first EU Western Balkan
Summit to take place in a western
Balkans country a sign of the Block's
renewed commitment to the region
I'm absolutely convinced that the future
of our children will be safer and more
prosperous with Western Balkans within
the EU Albania Bosnian Herzegovina
Kosovo North Macedonia Montenegro and
Serbia have waited for years to join the
EU but progress has been slow held back
by the need for reforms and divisions in
the EU over enlargement but Russia's war
in Ukraine has fueled momentum for the
process on all sides we are
full-heartedly supporting the
enlargement program process and the
regional integration
this year has seen a lot of progress
It's the moment to
send to all the people in the region but
first and foremost to the Albanian
people
that the European Union is
here for us the EU wants to reassure the
Western Balkans that they're very much
part of the EU family in
eders are concerned that if people
become disillusioned with the block
it'll be harder to counter the influence
of Russia and China in the region
for now supporting the region for
joining the EU is high at an
anti-government protest near the summit
people were angry with the prime
minister's policies but few questioned
where their Futures should be
Albania has historically always been a
European country it has emerged from a
Dark Age of Communism and suppression of
Human Rights so for us the EU will be a
guarantor of Rights and Freedoms
many people in the region particularly
the young are eager for the
opportunities that being part of the EU
would bring but the reality is the full
membership is still likely to be years
away Natasha Butler Al Jazeera Tirana